okay thanks it's interesting to see so
many faces I know kind of packed so
closely on most of them friends so
anyway let's let's let's knock into that
I only have so much time okay so what
I'm going to be talking about is aqua
skating turing machines this is based on
joint work with venkata Coppola and
Allison Bishop Luke oh okay so as
listening to the previous talks and we
are hopefully in this age of obfuscation
where we can do something pretty amazing
we can take one existing program run it
through some compiler that we're going
to call an office cater and out we get
is another program that is functional
equivalent to the first one that is it
does the same thing but we hope in some
sense it makes it maximally
unintelligible hides the secrets of how
we did the first one okay so um it's
been a long time coming but um now we're
at the point where we at least have the
first had in 2013 on the first viable
candidate for general-purpose office
keishon from the ggh RSW paper and here
we were able to do it for obfuscating
any polynomial size circuits okay so
circuits are great because they're a
general model of computation we can
incense in some sense do everything from
it but the main drawback with the model
is that the description size of the
circuit will scale with the maximum time
it takes to compute a function and in
general there might be some functions
where the description is actually really
small and the Turing machine model but
perhaps can on one run for much longer
okay so for that reason on what we like
to be able to do is would be even cooler
in some sense to be able to do
obfuscation for the Turing machine model
where the description could be much less
than the computation timer space and
I'll just mark this is an actual Turing
machine I found online it was kind of
cool cool to look at in action ok and
the advantages for using obfuscation for
Turing machines are that first
efficiency of encoding we can also
hopefully do office keishon without
bounds like some program which can take
an arbitrary length input I'm also for
problems like delegation of computation
or time like puzzles they naturally work
much better
when we're talking about Turing machine
obfuscation than circuit okay so towards
this go there has been previous work to
do it and what what they did was to
build it on some type of definition
known as different inputs obfuscation
what different input sophistication
essentially says is that no polynomial
time attacker can distinguish between an
office keishon of program p 0 and 1 a p1
unless it happens to somehow know a
point at which these two programs differ
so this is inherently some type of
extraction or knowledge problem which
says that if you're distinguishing
perjuring these two I know that you know
something about it okay and there's a
won't go into the details but there's a
kind of a cluster of theorems around
this showing that if we have different
inputs for circuits plus we have snark /
snarks we can translate this into
different inputs obfuscation for Turing
machines ok however ok so the main issue
though is do we really believe in these
knowledge assumptions and one
interesting result came out a year ago
which was essentially saying that there
was a conjecture that there was that
there was a clash of functionalities for
which we could not different inputs
securely differing inputs off escaped it
so if you actually believe this
conjecture which I you know I personally
happened I personally happen to believe
it what this does is it sort of says
that different inputs is somewhat in the
same boat as virtual black box office
keishon with the whole negative result
of Barack at all and oh and i'll mention
recently we've been working on so i mean
we've been working on some work with
different inputs obfuscation based on
sub exponential hardness assumptions so
i mean here i didn't get the chance to
it just realized on the fly we weren't
sure if you're going to show that yet or
not okay anyway and there's also other
things like public point different
inputs obfuscation for for which there
is no known impossibility results but
does not lie commits early was talk
about some work of ours where we're
trying to prove for indistinguishability
obfuscation there's not really it's not
clear like if there's even a path to
proving things with different inputs
office keishon so for that reason i
personally think that
indistinguishability obfuscation is in
some sense the right definite
Shin to be working with at least for
some definition of right and this is
actually a slide I put up about a year
and a half ago at the chef Ian Silvio
fest which is what we hope the future
can be hopefully we can build
indistinguishable deification from some
standard assumption like learning with
errors would be you know a nice example
of course and on the other side of it we
like to be able to build up most of
cryptography from it okay and we've
actually on been pretty successful in
that bottom half of the picture I just
picked out a few random or arbitrary
examples of this there's actually many
many more work done by many people in
this area and i'll even assert that on
the top half we've actually have had
some progress the first approach i was
put forth by something for witness [ __ ]
shin put forth by Gentry leuco and
myself and then the work admit talked
about with Gentry leuco emitted myself
where we can try to break it down to a
simpler problem and in some sense that
this has worked we have broken it down
to a simple problem the main remaining
issue i'll be at a big one is just more
the mathematics of these multilinear
maps do we believe in them but at least
we have a problem which we can go on and
narrow down and also mention there's
also a second approach that works like
the first one up into the point that
they do this hybrid over all inputs for
compact fe but then at that point it
deviates later on i think someone else
will be talking about this work later on
ok and the last thing i really want to
emphasize because i know there are some
doubts you know with these attacks and
multilinear maps I don't see any
fundamental reason why this can't happen
like there's no real good art I mean I
can see why it's hard I can see why I
can take a lot of research effort I
don't see why it shouldn't happen you
know whether it's two three four or five
or you know even more years this
definitely it doesn't seem to be
anything hiding in there given all the
other stuff we can do it I think this
should be doable ok so now we're coming
towards we want to be able to use io4 we
have indistinguishably obfuscation four
circuits or at least we believe we do
and what we want to do is to get
indistinguishable obfuscation for Turing
machines so the most natural thing is ok
how can i take i 0 for circuits and
somehow bootstrap it or somehow be able
to turn this into io for Turing machines
and so for this I'm going to point out
two recent works on towards this which
I'll call that have taken the entire
state programming approach okay and the
main idea here let me kind of trail
things is that we're essentially going
to have this yellow this yellow
highlighted thing here somehow be an
office case an office gated circuit and
it's going to essentially run the Turing
machine step you know a step where you
you know right to the Turing machine you
know you decide what the next position
is do you move left to right and what is
the output so essentially we're going to
just have some type of iterated circuit
which we I'm taking some state throw it
into the sophisticated program get some
state back out and just keep on
iterating it over and over again and
here I know turn I know obfuscation
takes in many inputs but here I'm just
going to focus on one particular input
ok so the way that these a now site
these works in a second the way that
these proofs work essentially are that
they do a proof by a hybrid and what
they do is they at some hybrid step T
let's say T steps in the hybrid and all
this gray area I'll just simulate or
pretend to do computation in some type
of way so I won't really be doing the
computation here won't really be doing
the computation here and then when i get
to state t i'm going to actually program
in what the state should be i'm going to
say ok now we're doing the computation
for real let me kind of somehow
indistinguishability somehow shove in
the state and from there we'll actually
do the real computation so the point
here for the proof is that we want to be
able to show that you know forestry
program in it here then we move it to
here and then we move it to here and
finally we move it to the very end where
all the computation is just pretend and
you can't actually tell which program is
used at least on that one input ok now
there's actually two different works
that are put forth this approach which
I'll call the entire state programming
one way was to use the out garbled
circuits where the office cated program
doesn't really do this trim machine
computation directly it more produces a
garbled circuit on the outside at one
step and this and then the next step it
produces another garbled circuit and
these things I'm interact with each
other and there's a second way the
second way where the computation is
actually done on the inside of here
and what we get at the end is some type
of sign state okay so these are two
different kind of approach summit sub
approaches to doing this but they both
have the same thing and there's also ram
candidate that they have this one that I
won't get into but they have one
important thing in common which is they
both have this thing where at some point
in the hybrid you just program and what
the state might be whether it's through
a sign state or through a yellow garbled
circuit there's going to be some Sim Sim
Sim then we program in the state and
then we actually start doing a
computation for real okay and however
the the problem with this or one
drawback of it is in order to program
the state in I essentially need my
original coding to be as big as the
entire taurima shape as the tire entire
Turing machine tape might actually get
so if it might get to be you know X
number of cells I need this programming
I need the circuit over here to be that
big okay and you might ask okay so why
the memory striction well it's
essentially what i said if we want to be
able to hardwire this in here if you
want to be able to hardwire this into
the circuit i need to actually say what
it's supposed to be so these approaches
just say okay it's in some sense a lot
like a standard you know hybrid approach
for proving yell garbled circuit here's
what you are at this point in time and
then the hybrid goes on from there okay
and you might ask well how big of an
issue is it like that we have that the
encoding time that the time and encoding
size grows with the maximum size of the
state and I think the answer is it just
simply depends on the computation right
if the maximum state stays very small as
close to the program description doesn't
really matter if it grows significantly
beyond that you know then it does ok and
I'll point out that this seems like a
fundamental you know a fundamental
property at least of this proof
structure where I'm going to program in
things and move forward from this point
okay so the point of this talk is you
know what can we do differently if we if
we want to be able to do I owe for
Turing machines and not have not have
this you know restriction on the maximum
size of the state how can we approach
this problem differently ok so let me um
kind of jump forward to it to the end of
things on the start
we're going to try to turn things around
a little bit in some sense what we
eventually get is we'll do a simulation
but more start the simulation and more
start the simulation at the at the end
of the computation and we've the hybrid
in the opposite direction so when we
finally get to a final final final thing
will be more something like this it'd be
the computation will go go go then it
will hit some point and then it will
pretend to do the computation until it
gets the very end where the final output
is hardwired and to move the hybrid
along what we're going to do is kind of
erase starting from the back towards
towards the front but one thing you'll
notice here is that a no point do I like
say okay let's just you know shove in
the state of program in the state at one
point in time okay so let's let's let's
see how this is done okay to actually
describe this I'm going to aim for a
smaller problem than office gation
something called a on something called
indistinguishability uh sorry something
called message hi gene encoding and the
idea here is to be able to have a Turing
machine m and I want to encode a message
such that a turn machine M and input X
and someone should be able to decode and
learn what the messages if M of X is
equal to one yeah it is
indistinguishable special for Turing
machines or is it completely trivial to
see how it should be defined um it's
yeah i did i'm not going to find a
formula in this talk is the short answer
but will kind of i'm going to define
this one and then we'll kind of build up
towards towards it okay thanks good
question ok so the smaller targets I'm
going to aim for right now that will
kind of zoom are focusing on will be
messaged hide in encoding where we'll
take as input then Cody Naga may take as
input a security parameter a Turing
machine M description em and input X
some time bound capital T just think of
t is 2 to the lambda for lack of
anything better and a message it outputs
and encoding and then the decoding algun
will take it and put this on this
encoding and either output the message
if M of X is equal to 1 or output bot
like reject if it's equal to 0
okay and the properties that we want
okay our first of all if M of X is equal
to one if it evaluates to 1 you should
be able to get the message and the
second one is an efficiency property
mainly saying that this encoding time
vote maybe it's better if I stay over
here that this including time should be
polynomial in lambda and the description
of the description message and it's
essentially independent of the running
time or it may be polynomial log of
maximum running time okay the decoding
time on the other hand can be polynomial
lambda and also the actual running time
of things okay so you could except for
you at violate the efficiency condition
like so in particular you like the
encoding the time took the time to
decide if M of X is equal to 1 will be T
star right and I want the encoding not
to take T star time that's in some sense
the whole point if you didn't mind about
that then yeah you just figure it out
yourself and make the encoding the
message sense okay so so that those are
the two conditions oh sorry capital T
because it doesn't make sense if I'm
ready for less than capital T
so if you're running star steps Quebec
so let's just assume we're only
interested in computations that take a
most to the lambda time decoding just
keep starting yeah okay and also the
security property we want is that if M
of X is equal to zero if it's not one
that it should be computationally
difficult to distinguish between an
encode in a message 0 and an encoding
message 1 and this is only when M of X
is equal to 0 you don't have that slide
and in addition to being sort of a
warm-up for the type of work we're going
to talk about today this actually is
already good enough for many problems
like delegation of computation when its
encryption and time lock puzzles so we
can actually already get some stuff out
of this message hiding encoding I should
also mention that he's shy and we
actually this kind of weakened
definition this is a weakened definition
of randomized encodings that was also
before this considered by you valla
Cheyenne ho tech we okay so the question
is how can we actually execute this type
of an idea and if i look at it there
must be two requirements one is if i
don't want the office cated program to
be operating on the entire state at one
time i needed to be operating on a
commitment to the memory that's so the
memory let's think of the memory of
something really really big and the
obfuscation needs to be operating on
something much smaller than it so it
needs to be able to operate on a small
commitment to the memory however if
you've messed around with IO proofs you
can tell it's sort of a tricky business
sometimes in that the IO definition only
works between functionally equivalent
programs so a lot of times to get an IO
proof to go through you need some type
of at least statistical or some type of
perfect binding so what we have here is
two requirements one is it has to
operate on a small commitment to the
large memory and the second one is that
it must be perfectly binding to it and
if you look at these commitments it
actually you know I guess james Van Der
Beek here gets upset because these
things are actually a contradiction to
each other right you can't
be perfectly committing to this was
something you know really small here
okay so how can we make I guess our
Dawson's Creek guy happier well the main
idea here is that we only if we're doing
a hybrid we don't need it to be
perfectly binding at every step of the
hybrid to everywhere in particular we
just need a certain hybrid I'm going to
be looking at this place on the train
and the touring tape and I just need it
to be buying you to there at that time
and then later on I needed to be buying
into somewhere else and later on to
somewhere else so what we're going to do
is we're going to have some type of a
primitive which allows us to be
perfectly binding to certain places at
certain times and we can move around
which memory which one is binding as
part of the proof as we progress okay
and I also point out that I don't know
how to pronounce this um kubicek and I'm
wicks also had some type of similar
selective enforcement idea for a
different problem multi-party
computation that I won't go into right
now okay so here's I mean here's one of
our main abstractions I won't have time
to get into all them for at least this
memory store for doing this and I we try
to coin this term io friendly tool so
the idea here is that we're going to
come pick a position I that will
actually be perfectly enforced okay and
if anyone's actually read the paper what
I'm going to show you now is not the
actual algorithms and the paper it's
going to be some type of simplified
version of them to fit in the talk okay
so we're going to have to set up
algorithms one is this a setup which
takes in the security parent 1 into
lambda and here T will also default as
the maximum size of the memory and
essentially initialize this really large
memory where everything is I guess
initially uninitialized in some type of
empty state and what outputs is some
public parameters on the storage this is
where everything's stored and a small
commitment which I'll call an
accumulator to the memory however this
also an alternative algorithm which is
called set up enforced which takes in
the same parameters and along with I
star which says we are going to be
perfectly binding to whatever happens to
I star that's essentially the
essentially the point of this here okay
so next there will also be in the
we're going to get at is that should be
hard to distinguish whether I executed
this setup or that set up next we're
going to have like a prep algorithm
which essentially reads from the storage
and also gives a proof that the reed was
done correctly and there will also be a
right to the storage algorithm and this
will be done by this outside part before
I pass it to the off you skated code and
running the term machine and finally
there would be an update accumulator
which takes as input the public
remembers the short accumulator will
take as input the message at position I
used to be and the message I that I want
to write and it will either see will
either reject if this proof pi wasn't
good or will give a new updated value to
the accumulator of the thing so this is
our memory store object and the fence
essentially we want everything to be at
least these operations to be polynomial
just in the security parameter and log
of T for the for these operations here
okay and the security / a property again
is that essentially I can't tell which
index I star that I'm going to be
perfectly binding to okay so let me
unfortunately there's just kind of too
much in the construction for me to like
go through it all but I'm going to try
to give a very rough picture of what's
happening here so again we have this
outside storage right and we're going to
like the decoding algorithm what it's
going to do is going to have the out
state storage which will consider of the
store the whole memory have a positional
cut accumulator the time step T we're on
the Turing machine position the Turing
machine state some iterator hash never
mind quite exactly what that is on the
values be through E and some type of
signature it's called a splittable
signature but don't worry about that
some type of signature is Sigma on be
through F ok and at each step what we're
going to do is the decode algorithm will
first read read at position on pause POS
gets the proof pie NM and it will just
kind of pass all this take all this junk
and pass it to lofi skated program the
office gated code will then essentially
perform a Turing machine step it will
check first check the hash the signature
of the accumulated proof rejected if any
of these things go bad poorly and then
it will output the step and update the
accumulator update the hash and sign all
these output values so it's going to be
just
you know we collect a bunch of stuff
running through the tour machine step
and then get out new stuff the important
thing here is that this big storage to
this large tape is actually not passed
in so point a is not passed in over here
okay then the decode algorithm will
update the storage value okay so let me
try to give you some sense about how
selective enforcement works for the
proof remember that we have that there
is an initial encoding and there is a
deterministic decode algorithm so there
is a correct sequence of steps if you
look at all these values the accumulator
position 0 the cumulated 0 accumulator
time step one time step 2 times step 3
that actually should be output you know
should be done in an honest computation
and we can just write these up on the
board here now the point is I want to be
able to do a hybrid to be able to anchor
it to the final results so you can only
learn the message if M of X is equal to
one so at hybrid tea we should want to
hardwire things such that a time step T
we only output a good signature let's
just say signature for now we're only
output a signature if the correct
accumulator value stars put in here okay
and I am simplifying things a lot from
the paper I'm kind of taking out a lot
of the details there's more things you
need to worry about so we're going to
hardwire in things to only work if the
good accumulator value is there and we
want to just move the hybrid along for
where we're first hardwiring and that
pretty much the initial state until we
hardwired in at the final state and at
that point we can not show the message
if M of X is equal to 0 okay so okay so
here's the main sub steps of the proof
we don't have too much time at hybrid
tea we're going to only output a good
signature if the input to this office
cated program is ack star of t minus 1
so this is a condition on the input of
the accumulator what we can do then is
we can think of an intermediate hybrid
tea an immediate hybrid where instead of
hard wearing at the input to the
accumulator we hardwired at the output
like so we're hard-wearing on on the
opposite side of the circuit and then we
you know go back to hardware at the next
step of t plus 1 we hardwiring at the
input before so I want to talk about is
how we get from here to here and this is
where
we're sure it is important that you take
your hybrids in the opposite direction
after after we get not not for message
hiding encodings is the short answer
yeah so try to get to that at the end
possible okay yeah so I am doing a
hybrid in the forward direction that
that's a good point okay so let me
describe from going from here to here
we're going to change from hard wearing
out the inputs to hardware at the output
and here we get another contradiction in
a sense in that I'm an IO proof for me
to get this trip through requires that
this input hardwiring is functional
equivalent to the output hard right in
general it won't be because this
accumulator could correspond you know
when a cumulative value could correspond
to many different memory values right so
the idea is before I try to execute this
IO type step of a proof I'm going to
first make it binding at the exact right
place that it needs to be so initially
in a normal set up for accumulator sub T
star there could be many different
openings of it but what I'm going to do
is I'm going to enforce it at position
star for where there's only one
particular opening that works and at
this point on the the input hard wirings
and the output our hardware ins would
actually be the same program in a sense
so this is where selective enforcement
comes in in that I'm going to
selectively enforced exactly at the
position I need to and it's going to
allow me to move this hybrid from like
programming at the input to programming
in at the output okay okay and then for
this other step of the proof that we
talked about here I won't really go into
this this doesn't have to do a selective
enforcement ok pretty short so this
would be some type of signature I'll
just call io gymnastics one important
thing was that it kind of got determined
not to use complexity leveraging for
this which made the problem kind of a
bigger pain and there's some some
primitive called splittable signatures
ok and so let me skip through that but
here is um actually shiz question I
think so what happened with the whole
backward simulation Dale okay so in
order to get actually in order to get to
indistinguishably obfuscation we need to
go from message hide in coatings to
randomize encodings which actually hide
the computation going on so construction
changes we go to in Bolivia's
machine we're going to encrypt our
symbols instead of just putting them out
in the clear and so the proof really is
is that we use these message hiding type
techniques to first anchor what the
output is going to be and then we erase
one simple backwards and then we undo
all that work and then we anchor in what
it should be over here then we erase
another symbol backwards and then so on
and so forth so actually um if the
computation takes let's say T star steps
the proof is actually T squared hybrids
kind of a nested so we have to pretty
much use all the stuff I told you just
to like a race one Turing machine
stumbled and do it all over again and so
on and so forth ok but at no point do we
program ok so the main so since I have
only just a little time left the main
technical summary is that on the
principle is we want to avoid this whole
state programming we want to just do
computation at no point just say here's
your entire touring tape selective
enforcement will be perfectly binding
when needed this idea does I actually
need this river simulation but then we
do this reverse order simulation using
these ideas to sort of anchor things and
erase ones symbol and going from
randomized encodings to iOS pretty
simple ok so let me I'm finally conclude
with just point out with one of these
will see next that one of the most
exciting things for me was to see in the
short period of time how many works
built on this oh did i misspell
something oh whoops ok well now you got
extra attention because this ok so sorry
about that okay so okay so so actually
in a relatively short amount of time a
few months has been a lot of works that
built on this one interesting thing is
with one exception all these kind of
weren't able to use it as a complete
black black box sort of needed to break
into these techniques and I guess deal
with a lot of pain is that more or less
correct and deal with these primitives
ok so um thank you and I'll take any
questions
you